ils viennent de boulistes ont su depuis
deux mois c'est ce que j'attendais
depuis 25 ans
[Musique]
non
bon
[Musique]
j'ai demandé une fois une société qui
travaille dans une usine pour avoir du
béton ce béton matelly vrai
malheureusement avec des produits acides
s'est produit à 6 de mômes occasionné la
perte de mes jambes pendant un an j'ai
été au centre des brûlés pour faire des
pansements tous les jours c'était un
vrai calvaire que j'en aurai plus
[Musique]
il a cité m me disait ben suit la
demande de votre patron
et de la scène sociale vous à budget de
la sécurité sociale le canton madison
j'ai repris le boulot le lendemain matin
je suis société ambulance couché avec le
bleu vient pointer vos cartons et je
suis parti avec deux câbles ce qu'ils
savent pas la saucisse exempt trois
jours ouvrés ampute par six mois j'ai bu
de la sécurité sociale on vend plus de
pop comme ça pour le plaisir et le dos
là on va rétabli mais à des petits
journaux mais parce que j'ai mis dix ans
pour nourrir
[Musique]
tous les autres je demande un quart
guilde me licencie dire de retrouver une
formation professionnelle parce qu'on
peut pas aller dans une autre société
s'engage et quelque part et à chaque
fois vous répondez tu coûte trop cher à
la société
proto compte
[Musique]
je pense après que toutes ces années
j'ai perdu ma dignité en tant qu'homme
et en tant qu'être humain qu'on me fasse
un licenciement correct que je puisse
retrouver une dignité surtout être
reconnus à leur juste valeur